[Música]
y
tal vez sea el escenario que muchos
también y que se está volviendo realidad
europa enfrenta una crisis de suministro
de gas y con el reloj corriendo en su
contra porque el invierno está a la
vuelta de la esquina según estimaciones
el bloque europeo cuenta con reservas de
gas natural que rondan el 60 por ciento
de la capacidad de almacenamiento pero
de hoy a diciembre deben ascender al 80
por ciento si quieren pasar un invierno
sin tantos contratiempos la crisis llega
por múltiples factores la guerra en
ucrania las sanciones económicas
impuestas a rusia y también la decisión
de la petrolera estatal rusa gazprom de
reducir el suministro de gas al bloque
europeo aduciendo problemas técnicos en
su principal gasoducto el norte stream 1
veamos más detalles en el siguiente
informe preparado por la redacción de
france 24
un grifo a cuentagotas el gigante ruso
de energía gazprom redujo el suministro
de gas a alemania a través del gasoducto
nord stream 1 dejándolo a sólo el 20 por
ciento de su capacidad según moscú el
corte se debe a problemas de
mantenimiento en las enormes turbinas
que presuriza en el gas pero los líderes
europeos aseguran que se trata de una
estrategia rusa para convertir los
suministros en un arma de guerra con el
fin de desestabilizar los mercados
energéticos del continente ni siquiera
tienen las agallas para decir estamos en
una confrontación económica bélica con
ustedes ya nos han contado una y otra
vez está ya sabes la rocambolesca
historia sobre las turbinas que
simplemente no es cierta míxquic nord
stream 1 transporta gas desde el puerto
ruso de víborg bajo el mar báltico hasta
greifswald en alemania las sanciones
occidentales por la guerra en ucrania
han detenido la apertura de su gasoducto
hermano north stream 2 en junio rusia
redujo el flujo del nord stream 1 al 60
por ciento de su capacidad alegando que
las sanciones impedían el regreso de una
turbina enviada a canadá para su
reparación tras un breve corte total el
suministro a través el gasoducto volvió
a ser del 40% antes del último anuncio
de nuevos cortes alemania afirma que las
turbinas en cuestión no están sujetas a
las sanciones de la unión europea así
que cualquier retraso en la devolución
de las piezas reparadas se debe a la
falta de documentos aduaneros rusos el
último corte de suministro se produce
cuando los países europeos se apresuran
a abastecerse de gas por temor a un
posible corte total por parte de moscú
en invierno cuando la demanda de
calefacción es máxima como medida casi
que desesperada la unión europea está
buscando otros mercados de suministros
azerbaiyán argelia ellos también están
buscando incrementar las importaciones
de gas procedente de eeuu un país que ya
se está frotando las manos con las
ventas del gas natural liquado a europa
entretanto los ministros de energía de
los 27 países que conforman el bloque
europeo acordaron reducir el consumo de
gas en un 15 por ciento algunas
excepciones como por ejemplo españa
reducirá el consumo solamente un 7%
hasta la primavera del 2023 todo esto de
manera obligatoria para poder ahorrar
casi 45 mil millones de metros cúbicos
de gas la decisión causó divisiones y
reproches al interior de la unión
europea sobre todo porque como decíamos
hay países como por ejemplo españa que
han avanzado en dejar de ser tan
dependientes del gas ruso su transición
a energías más verdes va por buen camino
y hay otras formas de abastecimiento y
no dependen tanto del gas ruso como por
ejemplo si le pasa a alemania pero ese
ahorro en que se traduce entonces para
los ciudadanos de la unión europea que
escenario en materia energética enfrenta
europa con un frío invierno que está
próximo a comenzar cuáles son las
opciones que tiene europa y como este
traspié en el camino entorpece ese ánimo
de una transición energética en el que
lidera pues prácticamente a nivel
mundial estamos hablando que europa es
uno de los líderes en esa transición al
uso de energías verdes en que hay otras
fuentes de energía pues ya lo vamos a
hablar con nuestros invitados entonces
esta europa en riesgo para este final de
año y está dispuesta a negociar con
rusia con tal de no congelarse durante
el envío boreal no vamos a discutir aquí
en el debate de france 24 para analizar
este tema saludamos a ramsés page el ex
asesor de temas de energía y economía se
conecta desde la ciudad de villahermosa
en el estado de tabasco en mexico y en
el estudio de france 24 está con
nosotros luis ferney moreno el es
analista de asuntos energéticos y
también director del departamento de
derecho minero energético de la
universidad externado de colombia que
está ubicada en la ciudad de bogotá en
la capital colombiana les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y sus comentarios también en
nuestras redes sociales estamos en
twitter en instagram y en facebook en
donde nos encuentra como france24 guión
bajo s arroba sant y luego que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 también en youtube
pueden seguir nuestra señal en streaming
aprovecho también para saludar a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa que ya están
disponibles en app el podcast spotify
deezer i tunes
pues muy bien voy entonces a mi pregunta
como punto de partida para el debate
para conocer posiciones de los invitados
comienzo entonces con ramsés en
villahermosa en mexico preguntándoles y
bueno primero dándole la bienvenida del
programa a ramsés gracias por estar con
nosotros y comienzo preguntándole si
llegamos al peor de los escenarios al
que más temíamos que era ver a europa al
borde de una crisis energética de cara
al invierno boreal
creo que todavía no hemos empezado a ver
la realidad todavía estamos empezando a
ver la parte de la punta
del saber y aquí creo que lo más
importante que se tiene que dejar en
claro es que el gas natural se ha
convertido en un arma estratégica en el
mundo cuando se pensaba que esta arma
por así llamarlo iba a tener y va a
influir más o menos como en el año 2035
con la invasión de rusia a ucrania se
adelantó una década y también se
adelantó una década la transición sobre
todo en la forma como se generará la
electricidad en el futuro esto que
conlleva que los países de la unión
europea van a tener que asegurar en el
mediano plazo no sólo el volumen de la
estrategia de almacenamiento que hoy
como bien comenta no pasa del 70 por
ciento de llegar al 80 por ciento sino
que tiene que buscar una alianza
estratégica fija fuerte de largo plazo
con estados unidos porque eeuu ya vimos
que en los últimos meses de este 2002 se
ha convertido en el principal exportador
a europa y el incremento ha incrementado
el volumen de gas sobre todo a este
continente y lo otro es que la unión
europea en 10 en conjunto y ya
determinaron que el gas natural se
considera una energía limpia aunque en
muchos países todavía no se considera al
gas natural en energía limpia y esto
abre la oportunidad para que sectores
financieros puedan apalancar proyectos
que estaban parados para poder generar
la electricidad con gas natural aquí el
problema es como lo que se dice del
dilema que es primero la infraestructura
o la materia prima aquí creo que va a
tener conjunto paralelo a europa ver
cómo pueden subsanar y sobre todo en
contra venencia de la parte de energías
del tipo renovables como la hidráulica y
solar que se tienen que hacer
inversiones muy fuertes para poder
minimizar en corto tiempo la el uso del
gas natural claro que cierran vamos a
hablar del tema de la infraestructura
también lo tengo como parte de los temas
a analizar en este programa le doy la
bienvenida a luis ferney aquí en el
estudio de france 24 gracias por
acompañarnos hoy aquí en el estudio del
programa y la misma pregunta para
conocer las posiciones estamos ya en el
peor de los escenarios era un escenario
temido o todavía como dice ramsés no
hemos visto lo peor de la situación de
acuerdo también consideró como reset
consideró de que no hemos visto
realmente lo que va a suceder
pero lo interesante acá al ver como
europa le apostó a la transición
energética en los últimos 20 años
y concretamente en los primeros últimos
10 años le ha puesto a la transición y
como vemos hoy que fenómenos como el
hobbit y el fenómeno este de la guerra
con ucrania y hoy estamos ante un gran
dilema o cuestionamiento es que la
transición energética que fue europa la
que emprendió en primer lugar y hoy no
está garantizando totalmente la
seguridad energética en estos países y
eso está esto implica necesariamente que
tenga que acudir a lo que se combatió y
a lo que se usó la transición que era
contra las energías fósiles el gas no
deja de ser una energía fósil sin
embargo hoy
evidentemente el gas ha sido un elemento
que se ha discutido como el elemento de
la transición como él
y estaba comprobando que no solamente es
el energético la transición sino que el
energético de la seguridad energética
para europa y entonces en ese orden de
ideas el gas se está volviendo el
energético que los europeos tienen que
volver a esa palabra de la seguridad
energética y también importante aquí es
que con pura transición energética
europa está demostrando que no era
posible hacer esa seguridad en quien
necesariamente tenía que contar con
estos energéticos que en un momento
determinado fue un cuestionamiento de
fondo de europa por el tema ambiental y
el sistema regulatorio del medio
ambiente etcétera antes consideramos y
consideró de que que lo que está por
venir a hacer mucho más en europa en
este momento estaba más bien como en una
etapa un estado de aguante están
tratando de aguantar y aguantarle a
quien aguantarle a putin que es una
estrategia de guerra efectivamente 7
putin y también aguantándole a los
ciudadanos porque los ciudadanos con con
los precios de importación del gas de
eeuu posiblemente sean mayores los
precios que lo que estaban vendiendo
rusia y eso hace que los ciudadanos en
estos momentos pueden estar soportando
mayores precios lara luis ferney
continuo con usted para hacer la ronda a
la inversa ya le voy a preguntar a
ramsés por la estrategia que puede tener
rusia bajo la manga con este suministro
de gas a europa le pregunto a ramsés
usted habla de la transición energética
se revalúa entonces ese concepto de la
transición que es un concepto que estaba
liderando europa varios países de la
unión europea durante la presidencia
rotativa le apostaba en el tema
medioambiental países como presidencia
rotativa recuerdo por ejemplo la de
dinamarca que le apostó mucho al tema de
las energías renovables se revalúa
entonces este concepto se aplaza esa
transición a nivel mundial esto a qué
costo para el cambio climático que
estamos viviendo que lo estamos
combatiendo supuestamente entre todos yo
pienso que sí va a haber
en corto y mediano plazo una revaluación
del tema de la transición energética
porque los europeos ya están pensando
incluso hacer uso del carbón algo que ya
habían sustituido con la transición
energética entonces harán uso del carbón
y seguirán siendo 'no uso del gas en ese
orden de ideas
puede haber una revaluación pero más
bien lo que va a demostrar algo que
nosotros hemos insistido a nivel de los
diferentes foros es que los países
tienen que pensar es en una coexistencia
en fuentes en vivir de la transición
energética para la seguridad energética
no va a ser suficiente definitivamente
va a requerir de estas fuentes que
evidentemente no estamos de acuerdo por
el tema ambiental
pero no queda más lugar que acudir en
cuando se trata de la diferenciación
como está pasando hoy si a estas fuentes
claro
ramsés en la ciudad de villahermosa en
mexico le preguntaba por la estrategia
del kremlin que tanto es entonces esto
un arma política que tanto quiere
presionar
moscú a la unión europea con el tema del
gas
y lo hemos visto en escenarios
anteriores que si quieren cerrar la
llave desde rusia la cierran como pasó
hace algún tiempo cuando ucrania no pudo
pagar por el paso de los gasoductos y
del gas ruso hacia europa a través de su
territorio
y creo que rusia lo que va a hacer es
que ya tiene dos herramientas en esta
guerra que estoy llamando desde el tipo
de vista energético en el mundo a partir
del 2022 ya no vamos a ver guerras
bélicas como tuvimos la primera de
segunda guerra mundial o lo que vamos a
tener son guerras energéticas económicas
y en este sentido rusia tiene dos armas
muy importantes la primera es el crudo y
el club depende mucho de los países de
lópez más y de los acuerdos que llegasen
a tener en agosto y en septiembre que se
libera pero sobre el gas natural creo
que es un arma que va a seguir
utilizando por lo menos estos 23 años
que siguen en función de que europa
depender de más del 40 por ciento del
suministro que manda rusia del gas
natural hoy lo vimos en la mañana y en
esta semana el gas el gas natural
licuado en los futuros estamos viendo
que este es en holanda donde está el
mercado donde se la valorización ha
llegado a 40 hasta 50 dólares el millar
de btu cuando hoy en eeuu en este lado
de americano más o menos está costando 8
dólares pero por día por vida de ductos
el costo del gas natural entonces europa
va a tener algo complicado en función
del punto de vista de una guerra
financiera en donde rusia va a tener que
ir buscando cómo ir apretando una mayor
cantidad a europa de cerrarle abrirles
decirles que hay problemas y todo esto
con el sentido de poner ganar unos
argumentos dólares más al incrementar la
incertidumbre en los mercados y algo muy
importante que hay que dejar muy claro
en europa si se está hablando de la
transición pero hay que hablar de la
transición desde un punto de vista de la
generación de la electricidad el
problema es que en el mundo a partir de
la pandemia surgió lo que se llama la
diplomacia ambientalista y esto lo
estamos viendo que eeuu lo está
liderando y se está creando un nuevo
mercado que yo creo que los primeros
cuestiones de 5 años va a tener una gran
influencia que es la captura del dióxido
de carbono es decir tú en el mundo vas a
poder utilizar carbón gas natural o
derivados de petróleo siempre y cuando
tú tengas la captura de dióxido de
carbono o las emisiones como
utilizas sean siempre por debajo de las
normas que estén especificadas en cada
país por lo tanto rusia va a tener un
arma para apretar más a europa en cuanto
a cuestiones económicas pero al mismo
tiempo va a tener un gran problema rusia
en cuanto a las emisiones de dióxido de
carbono sobre la huella de carbono
ramsés pero también se arma como una
especie de círculo vicioso porque se
bombea menos gas hacia la unión europea
para entonces los precios suben entonces
las arcas del kremlin reciben más dinero
esto sirve para financiar más la guerra
extenderla prolongar la una guerra que
creíamos iba a durar unas cuantas
semanas ya vamos a cumplir prácticamente
seis meses
de estos combates y esta presencia
militar rusa en el este en la región del
donbass y puede seguir apretando a
europa a través del gas el precio no hay
forma de bajarlo a través de otros
mecanismos rusia siempre va a seguir
ganando por tanto que se le mire
si al menos que en eeuu que ya por
ejemplo de luisiana terminaron de
construir una planta de gas natural
licuado y tarda más o menos una planta
de licuefacción entre 25 y hasta 30
meses para poner el cual es operar van
va a depender mucho a europa de cuánto
tienen la capacidad su socio con su
socio que es en este momento dado eeuu y
países como por ejemplo
del lado del atlántico que podía hacer
colombia o brasil de cómo mandar gas
natural o mexico también como mandar gas
natural va a ser mucho como para poder
influir pero creo que europa depende hoy
en día en la reacción que pueda tener
sobre todo eeuu en las inversiones
rápidas de poder poner tener plantas de
licuefacción hacer de monos eeuu produce
demasiado gas y tiene ese problema que
hoy se convirtió en el principal
exportador tanto de crudo como de gas
natural licuado claro no sé me adelanté
ramsés con el tema américa latina que ya
lo vamos a analizar las posibilidades
que para nuestros países en el luis
ferney hablemos de esa decisión que
tomaron en la unión europea los 27
países de hacer una reducción en el
consumo
15% algunos países como lo mencionaba yo
españa llega al 7 por ciento esto volvió
a mostrar sobre la discusión las
discrepancias que hay al interior de la
unión europea entre países del norte y
países del sur incluso se formó ya un
bloque los picks los cerdos que son
portugal italia grecia y españa- que la
reclaman precisamente al norte porque
ellos tienen otra forma de suministro y
no necesitan recortar tanto esta
estrategia puede funcionar le sirve a la
unión europea le da tiempo para llegar a
ese 80% de almacenamiento de cara al
invierno muy bien me parece
que esta estrategia es
complementaria a la que es la estrategia
principal ellos están buscando
básicamente un mayor almacenamiento de
gas como cuando hay una guerra uno se
aprovisiona los europeos están
aprovisionándose están tratando de
de buscar en lo posible llegar a
aumentar ese almacenamiento porque eso
ayudaría mucho es la estrategia
principal pero eso está complementado
básicamente con con el razonamiento y
podríamos decir con la eficiencia del
consumo que podría de cierta forma
ayudar el problema es el el invierno o
sea hablar en el invierno de
racionalización hablar de eficiencia de
consumo en un periodo tan fuerte como es
que se consume mucho más gas como
energético va a ser un poco difícil yo
creo que la estrategia de una eficiencia
en el consumo va a ser una política que
en cierta forma tendrá que implementarse
pero no va a ser tan eficaz en la medida
de que la eficiencia de consumo se hace
es en un periodo muy fuerte de consumo
de energéticos sí y además que no es lo
mismo un invierno en el sur de españa o
en el sur de italia que un invierno en
suecia o en polonia acuerdo si es muy
distinto ramsés su opinión sobre esta
estrategia de la unión europea de
acuerdo 15 por ciento
y ahorro en el uso del gas
creo que le dejó el miuto ha activado y
no lo oímos ramsés
adelante lo tenemos
lo que odio de este 15 por ciento es muy
complicado a ver por qué porque va a
depender mucho del sector manufacturero
que utiliza el gas natural va a ser muy
complicado en los hogares que va a estar
en octubre noviembre diciembre porque
cada hogar va a determinar cuánto es lo
que necesita de poder calorífico para
poder mantener sus hogares calientes y
como yo lo comenta no es el mismo
invierno que se tiene en españa que más
al norte como puede ser el reino unido
dinamarca o con la parte de noruega aquí
lo más importante yo creo que están
centralizados sobre todo en los ahorros
en sobre todo en la industria y la
industria que es lo que puede ocasionar
que puede causar una desaceleración
económica y si ya hay una incertidumbre
en el mundo de una recesión económica lo
que vamos a ver es que podemos tener un
crecimiento muy pobre por el último
trimestre en europa y esto podría
complicar el primer trimestre del 2023
para europa lo que aquí es algo muy
importante en el sentido del ahorro en
dónde va a ser y va a influir
principalmente y sobre todo es el
industria donde yo estoy observando de
éste precisamente pongo ese tema sobre
la mesa esto económicamente en que se
traduce entonces para europa para el
crecimiento muchos países están teniendo
problemas con una inflación alta y es
difícil para algunos países de europa
volver a reactivar la economía después
de los cierres de la pandemia hago la
ronda la inversa entonces vuelvo con
ramsés y ya pasó con luis ferney muy
bueno y esto es esto lo vimos en la
inflación por ejemplo eeuu que está de
10 por ende en méxico está arriba de 8
en europa hay muchos países que tienen
problemas con la inflación y creo que la
desaceleración económica va a crear una
incertidumbre más si es que llega a ver
a partir del mes de septiembre octubre
que se está esperando en algunos
mercados y esto va a complicar mucho
sobre todo el producto interno bruto del
pib de los países y sobre todo lo que a
mí más me preocupa es el inicio del
primer trimestre recordemos que en todo
el mundo lo más complicado en los
lugares y en la industria es iniciar en
enero las actividades por los ajustes
que se van a tener imagínate el día
primero de enero si tienes una inflación
en un país por del 10% tendré que hacer
un ajuste de tus costos a la inflación
observada y esto lo que va a ocasionar
es que se te van a incrementar los
costos de tu producción sus servicios y
todo lo demás grandes imaginemos que
metemos que en invierno no tuvieron una
buena cantidad de gas natural en las
reservas cayeron al 20 por ciento en
europa imagínense si no tienen la
cantidad de gas necesario y el dinero
necesario para poder comprar el gas y
hacia eeuu o rusia sería una gran
incertidumbre y por eso vemos los
mercados tan volátiles que estamos
viendo en los últimos días aquí lo que
más les
sorprende es una alta incertidumbre de
los próximos meses alta incertidumbre de
luis ferney por este lado su perspectiva
en términos económicos y le añade un
componente más alemania- motor económico
de la unión europea y es el que más
depende del gas ruso es el que más
problemas va a tener para poder
garantizar el suministro esto para
europa ya más o menos lo está explicando
ramsés pero para el mundo para la
incertidumbre que se está viviendo a
nivel mundial en términos económicos
definitivamente estamos en una
mundial es mundial y el hilo y hay que
agregarle a esto es que esta guerra con
ucrania y los efectos que está
produciendo está contribuyendo aún más
esta incertidumbre a tal punto tal que
recuerdo mucho que antes de la cob y se
hablaba ya en europa de la pobreza
energética ya se está hablando de los
altos costos de los energéticos y había
una gran preocupación hoy es aún más
extremo todo este tema de la pobreza
energética porque realmente los
ciudadanos están hoy pagando mucho más
en su factura en europa de lo que se
pagaba antes de la pandemia o durante la
pandemia y definitivamente este este
esta situación le está generando a de la
guerra o con ucrania y rusia él están
generando europa unos mayores costos y
costos no solamente a los ciudadanos
sino costó al gobierno porque el
gobierno también que es tiene una serie
de presupuestos de subsidios pero al
mismo tiempo los ciudadanos tienen que
de su ingreso hoy dedicar más parte de
su ingreso
los energéticos en esos países entonces
esto está implicando necesariamente que
europa tendrá que va a estar afectado en
su crecimiento no creo que entren en
recesión pero europa toman es unas
economías muy fuertes pero si afecta el
crecimiento y el crecimiento europa va a
afectar a nivel global y no va a generar
una incertidumbre a nivel global
entonces en ese sentido ese es el efecto
que pudo producir ahora alemania
definitivamente alemania
era el ejemplo para todos de la
transición energética era el ejemplo de
la implementación de energías renovables
pero estamos sorprendidos muchos de que
trabajamos temas energéticos estamos
sorprendidos que europa hoy en caso
concreto a alemania ese es el caso que
estamos mirando el caso de alemania
y no está ayudando todo este tema de la
transición que en que se invirtieron
muchos recursos
no está ayudando a a conjurar esta
crisis y el efecto de estos combustibles
fósiles en alemania se está sintiendo
claras que les parece como si les estará
jugando en contra el grande en contra
hasta el punto de que escuchados ya al
ministro de energía de alemania
invocando la posibilidad de abrir las
plantas termoeléctricas a base de carbón
y entonces esto esto muestra
muestra que alemania pues el alemán ya
no se va a quedar para alemania pienso
que puede conjurar ese tema pienso
conyuntural si hay certidumbre pero es
constructura muy posiblemente esto es un
juego geopolítico en el que todos están
forjando hasta dónde aguanta en un
término momento esto puedo reventar que
sería la incertidumbre de la tercera
guerra claro se o definitivamente
arreglar o arreglar y sentarse en
arreglar esto luis ferney continuó con
usted ramsés para que hablemos de las
oportunidades y las salidas que tiene
europa para para esta crisis aquí hay
oportunidades para otros países para
para que europa ingrese en esos mercados
para poder abastecerse ya vimos a italia
negociando con argelia a ursula von der
leyen en bakú negociando con azerbaiyán
y ya se habla de esos yacimientos de gas
que hay en las costas de chipre que se
están volviendo ya como muy atractivos
para los inversionistas también cuáles
son las oportunidades para otros países
para entrar a este mercado y cuáles son
las oportunidades para explorar otro
tipo de fuentes de energía
definitivamente
américa latina hay algunos países que
vamos a tener unas ciertas oportunidades
para la tienda entre esa coyuntura para
exportación de nl que sería básicamente
bolivia o algo pero no tanto colombia
colombia realmente produce consume lo
que produce y por lo tanto colombia en
esta coyuntura no sería beneficiario los
beneficiarios de finales trinidad-tobago
bolivia perú muy posiblemente algo de
argentina por el tema de vacas de este
proyecto importante de fracking que
ellos implementaron y ese serían los
países que más se beneficiarían no
conozco muy bien el caso de méxico pero
aquí estarán se nos puede explicar pero
realmente
los países productores de gas en américa
latina se van a beneficiar
cogiendo ese gas y ponerlo en genes para
poder exportar en forma líquida a europa
y evidentemente pues son precios muy
competitivos los que podría tener
gracias hay unas muy buenas
oportunidades para estos países francés
y su opinión oportunidades quienes
pueden ingresar ya hablaba yo de
azerbaiyán posiblemente pueda plantearse
y ponerse también en la mesa la
necesidad de suavizar un poco las
sanciones a irán para que le pueda
suministrar gas a europa a través de los
gasoductos que cruzan turquía cuál es el
escenario que usted vislumbra
bueno el escenario que vislumbró es que
hay una gran oportunidad sobre todo y lo
vuelvo a recalcar
eeuu-méxico en américa latina los países
que acaban de comentar básicamente
bolivia del problema de solo es el
transporte que hay que dar una buena
vuelta por el continente y brasil y del
lado del medio oriente ya vimos que el
presidente bailén fue en últimas
instancias en arabia saudita y yo creo
que arabia saudita podría ser una parte
fundamental también para poder surtir el
gas que se está haciendo falta en europa
aquí la pregunta no es tanto si se
tienen la materia prima para poder
sustraerse del subsuelo el problema es
el transporte el problema del transporte
es que hay muy pocos barcos y que estén
disponibles para hacer los movimientos
sobre todo que el gas natural licuado
estos barcos tienen que tener y tiene
una característica muy especial y son de
muy complicado si no los hay y podamos
decirlo en el mercado que pudieran
cubrir una alta demanda
lo otro es que los países que tengan la
oportunidad cuál es la capacidad que
tienen sobre todo financiera para poder
construir una planta de licuefacción
para que pueda ser su vida un barco
porque una planta más o menos puede
tardar entre los 18 a los 30 meses para
poder operar entonces esto va a depender
mucho de la reacción y sobre todo que
dependiendo del país si es una empresa
privadas que pueden hacerlo pudiera
haber una rápida respuesta pero si son
países en algunas de las situaciones
donde son empresas nacionales quienes
controlan como en el caso de méxico
bueno va a ser un poco complicado y otro
punto que yo quería comentar aquí
santiago creo que algo muy importante
que se nos está escapando es que en
europa tienen también otra gran
incertidumbre que es el subsidio esto
qué significa que van a tener que dar un
subsidio a los industriales y también
tiene que ser aplicado este subsidio y
hay que ver cuánto va a ser de octubre a
noviembre dependiendo de cuanto a lo que
lleguen almacenar porque este subsidio
va a ser un dinero que va a saber del
erario público de cada uno de los países
que en dado caso tenga que bajar el
precio del costo de la electricidad ya
lo vimos en días pasados que los costos
de la electricidad en españa en ciertos
lugares alcanzaron más de los 100 los
más de los 200 euros
el mega watt y esto creo que tenemos que
verlo en este sentido aquí lo importante
de las oportunidades va a ser sobre todo
el transporte quién es el que tiene el
transporte y quién está dispuesto a dar
lo claro el subsidio porque no es lo
mismo alemania dando subsidios que es el
motor económico de la unión europea a
croacia que acaba de entrar oficialmente
la unión europea que está por adoptar el
euro y no tiene la misma el mismo
músculo económico que pueda tener
alemania o que pueda tener francia o los
países bajos me deja usted pensando
ramsés en cuanto al terme el tema de la
infraestructura esto quiere decir que
también europa en esto prácticamente
esta crisis por ponerlo en palabras más
simples también los cogieron con los
pantalones abajo en cuanto al tema de
infraestructura para abastecerse de gas
y esto demuestra una vez más
dependientes que estaban de los
gasoductos procedentes de rusia sí y hay
que dejar al público hay dos formas que
tú puedes tener el gas por medio de un
barco si llegan un puerto comprimido
llega se descomprime y se mete a los
ductos pero no es lo mismo que viene de
un campo de un yacimiento de una de una
planta de procesamiento de gas como por
ejemplo de rusia que llega en un volumen
constante a través de un ducto entonces
en lugar de rusia era un volumen
constante con una infraestructura de
ductos que cumplía con la demanda que
tenía en este dado caso europa al tener
gas natural licuado va a depender de la
capacidad y la velocidad y los barcos
que van a poder descargarse en cada uno
de los puertos donde existen plantas que
puedan descompresión ar este gas
entonces la infraestructura en cuanto
ductos que puedan llevar un gas natural
que bien que es el que se cumple utiliza
comentó en europa no hay ningún
inconveniente el problema en la
infraestructura puerta de los puertos
claro que tengan la capacidad poder
bajar el gas que viene comprimiendo
hemos visto en ese tema a un país
bastante organizado y es ya que logró
organizar lituania y estonia lograron
organizar unos puertos de hecho estonia
ya no depende del gas ruso porque logra
abastecerse de gas a través de este gas
natural licuado que tiene en un puerto
sobre el báltico ya me quedan pocos
minutos para terminar el programa se fue
muy rápido hoy casi nunca nos pasa si
voy entonces a dar paso a las
conclusiones para allá para llegar al
cierre comienzo entonces con luis ferney
conclusiones siempre lo digo no hay bola
de cristal no sabemos qué va a suceder
pero qué panorama ve usted de aquí a
diciembre ve usted a europa en una
crisis más profunda
discusiones y enfrentamientos bruselas
moscú como lo ve usted yo yo europa
aguantando veo
con un alto grado de aguante
con las estrategias que están montando
de almacenar almacenamiento
y un poco sobre racionalizar el consumo
lo veo aguantando hasta el límite en que
putin nos quiere llevar oyó que los
ciudadanos aguante porque muy
posiblemente a diciembre estaremos
viendo en europa muchas protestas como
en otros países claro lance su
conclusión rápidamente por favor
mi conclusión es vamos a ver a una
europa que va a tener una alianza
estratégica de largo plazo con eeuu y
con otros países que le van a dar el gas
natural y vamos a ver una transición
energética a nivel mundial que se
esperaba que en el 2050 se tuviera una
generación de electricidad con energías
limpias y esto se va a adelantar cuando
menos una mega acá a 15 años esta
transición el problema aquí es
cuestiones de dinero y el que va a
aguantar y lo voy a llamar así el día de
que vamos a tener en 2023 va a ser en el
mes de octubre cuando sepamos realmente
si llegaron al 80 por ciento de su
almacenamiento en europa si no llegan
ese día de va a ser muy complicado por
las cuestiones que rusia va a tener como
estrategia recortar influjo de gas en
ese momento bueno pues así está el
panorama si están las cosas esperaremos
hasta octubre y hasta diciembre cuando
empiece ya oficialmente el invierno en
el hemisferio norte a ver cómo está la
situación allí cómo van a ser los
europeos para enfrentar esta situación
este desabastecimiento de gas
como decía ramsés y logran hacer el
almacenamiento necesario a luís fernando
y a ramsés en villahermosa el mexico les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 muchisimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros y
ustedes también muchísimas gracias por
la sintonía pueden seguir dejando los
comentarios y preguntas que deseen a
través de las redes sociales y también
me despido de nuestros
televidentes o las personas que también
nos están escuchando a través de nuestro
podcast muchas gracias por su sintonía
siguen con france24
[Música]